m
politique contractuelle le gouvernement
ne cède pas le nombre des demandes
d'emploi reste très élevé et les offres
diminue malaise en espagne à la veille
du référendum
les français organiseront peut-être une
transat en 78 la construction navale en
difficulté c'est le dossier là messieurs
bonsoir après la politique en vedette
hier comme prévu c'est l'actualité
sociale qui prend le relais aujourd'hui
avec d'abord cette petite phrase
attendue à l'issue des négociations
charbonnages de france la progression
garantie des salaires de 2% ne sera pas
assurée l'année prochaine comme à l'edf
gdf le gouvernement par entreprise
nationalisée interposés n'a pas céder
d'un iota et n'a pas varié de ses
positions la lutte contre l'inflation
passe d'abord par une progression des
salaires égale à celle des prix égale
les principes ailleurs raymond barre ne
manque pas une occasion de le rappeler
mais la passe est enchaînement un petit
peu mécanique pas de grève aux
charbonnages ce n'est pas le même
scénario qu'à l'edf où il y aura des
arrêts de travail et donc des coupures
de gaz d'eau et de courant
demain et apprennent comme on pouvait
s'y attendre
aucun accord n'a été signé ce matin
entre les syndicats et la direction des
charbonnages sur les salaires 1977
la progression de 2% du pouvoir d'achat
ne sera pas garantie l'an prochain c'est
la conséquence d'une situation
économique difficile dit la direction
c'est une nouvelle remise en cause de la
politique contractuelle affirment les
représentants des mineurs on se reverra
en janvier mais d'ici là le ton monte à
la proche des fêtes dans le bassin
houiller ou les syndicats pourraient
appeler à des arrêts de travail
symbolique et dès ce soir greffes
partielles aussi demain au gaz et à
l'électricité
c'est la conséquence de la rupture
consommée vendredi dernier entre les
partenaires sociaux
mais les coupures d'eau
rang seront limitées de 14h30 à 16h30
mardi et de 9h30 à 11h30 mercredi en
plein hiver et l approche des échéances
électorales
les syndicats ne veulent manifestement
pas trop gêner les usagers et se mettre
à dos l'opinion publique à ces coupures
de courant les entreprises seront quand
même ouverte c'est ce qu'a demandé le
cnpf à ses adhérents voici maintenant un
autre type de conflit social sans aucun
rapport avec le précédent mais dont les
incidences pourrait gravement vous
touchez il s'agit d'un domaine qui je
pense vous est cher puisque vous êtes
devant votre poste de télévision
c'est lui la télévision tout simplement
vous savez que depuis près d'un mois les
comédiens mais artiste de variété en
général sont en grève et que cette grève
est en train de compromettre très
sérieusement les programmes de fin
d'année ces petits cadeaux que chaque
chaîne et permettez moi de vous le dire
en toute modestie notamment antenne 2 de
ces petits cadeaux que la télévision
mais dans vos souliers depuis 2h 2h30
les comédiens négocier à nouveau avec le
patron de la lfp
la société qui assure la fabrication la
plupart des émissions on disait un peu
que ce serait la négociation de la
dernière chance
cinquante tournage interrompu les
plateaux des buttes chaumont désert
trois syndicats de comédiens tous
travaillant pour la radio et la
télévision tous en grève depuis le 18
novembre pourquoi les comédiens
réclament plusieurs choses d'abord un
accroissement des émissions de création
car ce ne sont pas les feuilletons
achetés tout faits aux amériques qui
font travailler les comédiens français
ensuite en cas de rediffusion
intéressement des comédiens en fanfare
et c'est capital pour les plus modestes
d'entre eux un salaire minimum
journalier une sorte de smic du cachet
après bien les escarmouches en ordre
dispersé les comédiens discute
maintenant avec un monsieur bons offices
unique russie red line patron la sfp
négocié au nom de toutes les sociétés
avec les comédiens dans son fief du
cinéma empire de cette réunion il peut
sortir soit une reprise des tournages
soit un blocage alors cela signifierait
un western de série b ou quelque chose
d'analogue sur vos petits écrans des
fêtes de fin d'année
cette entrée des artistes c'est celle de
l' empire la grande salle de la ffpm une
vague ramener les artistes qui sont
entrés ici ne l'ont pas fait bon de
monter sur la scène depuis près de trois
heures maintenant le représentant
négocié en furent mis ici avec les
patrons des chaînes de télévision et
sous la présidence de monsieur edeline
ils négocient leurs revendications or
jusqu'ici a filtré de cette réunion à
huis clos
il semble toutefois que compensent vers
incertaine optimisme mais si un accord
venait à survenir
il est très peu probable qu'ils
surgissent avant une heure très avancée
de la soirée
ou peut être même de la nuit troisième
type de conflit celui des chantiers
navals de saint nazaire
là encore il s'agit de salaire mais le
partenaire d'en face n'est pas l'état
c'est une société privée
alstom atlantique les grévistes ont
évacué ce matin le pétrolier bella mia
qu'ils occupaient depuis trois jours
tout ça s'est passé sans heurts son
intervention de la police et les baux
ciation ont même pu s'engager puisque la
direction a accepté de rencontrer
l'intersyndicale
elle avait mis pour préalable et
vacation de ce pétrolier car il est très
rare dans l'histoire des chantiers
navals je mets donc à paarl france très
rare qu'un bateau soit occupé depuis ce
matin ce pétrolier géant de 550 mille
tonnes n'est plus occupé en effet à 9
heures l'intersyndicale cgt cfdt fo des
chantiers navals a pris la décision de
mettre fin à l'occupation qui durait
depuis le 7 décembre
l'action des grévistes continuent
cependant et des pics et ouvriers
restent en faction devant le bella mia
le conflit n'est donc pas terminée loin
de là mais ce soir on apprenait que la
direction a accepté de rencontrer
l'intersyndicale est donc d'ouvrir des
négociations
reste à savoir ce que pourra et ce que
voudra accorder la direction le conflit
avait éclaté à propos du renouvellement
de l'accord salarial qui intéresse dix
mille travailleurs et il risque de
donner lieu à des négociations très
difficiles car il ya en toile de fond
les problèmes graves que connaît la
construction navale en france en ce
moment
d'ailleurs nous reviendrons plus
largement sur saint nazaire avec un
dossier en fin de journal sur ce
problème des chantiers navals
voilà donc plusieurs types de conflits
plusieurs éruptions mais qui ne donne
pas l'impression que le climat social
est pourri dans le jargon syndical ce
n'est pas ce que l'on appelle un automne
chaud alors pourquoi là cela tient
d'abord beaucoup à l'attitude des
syndicats on a un petit peu l'impression
qu'ils freinent leurs bases ils
pratiquent un certain attentisme
serait ce un choix entre une tactique
syndicale court terme et une approche
politique à plus long terme c'est la
question que nous avons posée à edmond
maire il est vrai que la réaction très
brutale du gouvernement que ce soit la
caisse d'epargne que ce serait dans le
secteur public et nationalisé temps à
mettre les travailleurs le dos au mur
une sorte de tout ou rien est un des
risques seraient que nous nous laissions
aller j'allais dire à la voie de la
facilité la facilité ce qu' il ya une
attente chez les travailleurs il ya une
inquiétude une hésitation et nous ne
voulons pas que cette attente submerge
finalement les possibilités d'action
mais nous ne voulons pas non plus que
par exemple nous partions grève
illimitée à l'edf ont plein hiver etc
finalement que nous allions l'échec
parce que l'opinion publique ne
l'accepterai pas il faut donc mettre au
point des formes d'action kaunas
diversifié intelligente sur une très
longue période pour obtenir les
résultats et pour faire en sorte que ce
ne soit plus nous payons dos au mur mais
le plan barre et ces mesures tout à fait
néfaste si j'ai bien compris bataille
syndicale à court terme et politique à
long terme exactement la bataille
syndicale à courtrai on doit même créer
de meilleures conditions donc la
bataille politique
victorieuse attentisme syndicale
peut-être attentisme patronales sans
doute et c'est peut-être pour tirer les
oreilles de ses patrons qui se refuse en
ce moment à investir
quel point le ministre est venu sur
l'avoir annoncé à une réunion qui
regroupait ce matin au ministère du
travail christian bilhac le ministre
françois ceyrac le président du cnpf et
plusieurs dirigeants d'entreprises
raymond barre est venu leur demander
d'améliorer par des investissements une
situation de l'emploi qui n'est pas bien
fameuse
on vient d'apprendre à l'instant les
chiffres des demandeurs d'emploi pour
novembre
un tout petit peu plus d'un million un
million 41 mille demandeurs d'emploi
toutes causes confondues
cela fait quelques milliers de chômeurs
de plus qu'en octobre avec les
variations saisonnières ça fait un petit
peu moins apparemment françois ceyrac
apparu réceptifs aux propos de raymond
barre il se trouve que le premier
ministre a considéré qu' étant donné
l'importance du problème de l'emploi
je crois effectivement que nous serions
nous les premiers malvenu à sous-estimer
l'importance et il devait marquer à la
fois la volonté gouvernementale dans ce
domaine est situé le problème de
l'emploi par le cadre d'une politique
générale de l'emploi il nous est dit et
tu me permets de rappeler sa phrase car
elle ne paraît très forte
l'inflation est à l'origine pour une
large part du chômage il faut lutter
contre l'inflation
pour améliorer l'emploi mais il faut en
même temps faire des efforts
particuliers pour accompagner cet effort
général vous partager son point de vue
sur ce point là tout bon c'est que dans
les mois qui viennent on hiver un petit
peu plus clair et que ça va s'améliorer
parce que les chiffres de l'emploi
aujourd'hui sont encore très mauvais les
chiffres de l'emploi sont mauvais et
c'est pas nous qui avons raconté des
histoires au pays à ce sujet nous avons
dit qu'elle était la vérité des choses
mais je pense que si d'une part sur le
plan économique les actions dont je
parlais sectorielle en particulier sont
engagés si d'autres pas on s'efforce à
partir d'une analyse des réalités et non
pas de vue de l'esprit d'agir sur le
plan précis des jeunes des femmes du
travail à mi temps etc
on doit pouvoir obtenir aussi une
amélioration et ceci à travers le
premier semestre 77 bon essayons d'y
voir clair après tout ce que nous venons
d'entendre ce que nous avons pu voir
ainsi à saint nazaire
les syndicats ont donné l'ordre
d'évacuer le navire sans qu'aucun casque
de policiers apparaissent à l'horizon
les ouvriers des chantiers navals ont
donc quitté en bon ordre
le superpétrolier qu'ils occupent
cette démarche responsable et à
rapprocher d'autres mouvements sociaux
les grèves de demain et après-demain edf
suffisamment spectaculaire pour alerter
l'opinion
pas trop dur cependant pour ne pas se
l'aliéner edmond maire à cet égard était
très précis il ya quelques instants les
suite de l'évacuation manu militari du
parisien libéré un baroud d'honneur
lundi dernier suivi presque
immédiatement de l'ouverture des
négociations
cependant que les attaques quasi
quotidiennes des camionnettes de
monsieur amaury par les ouvriers du
livre ont cessé d'une façon générale et
mis à part le conflit de la case départ
de paris où personne ne risque de perdre
son emploi
quoi qu'il arrive cela dit en passant
les syndicats tentent bien de mobiliser
les salariés mais se garde de les lancer
dans l'aventuré
pour une fois c'est vrai la mobilisation
n'est pas la guerre alors pourquoi trois
raisons que je crois il faut reprendre
on n'a jamais vu de confit social
généralisé à dix jours de noël
le coeur n'y est pas les licenciements
qui se multipliaient ça c'est ce qu'il
ya de plus inquiétant créer un sentiment
d'insécurité peu favorable au
développement de grandes grèves
c'est ce que rappelle d'ailleurs
férocement michel jobert
dans sa lettre à un chômeur à quelques
mois d'échéances électorales en fin
d'échéance électorale décisive
les syndicats qui pour la plupart
souhaitent la victoire de la gauche
entendent montrer qu'ils ne sont pas des
fauteurs de troubles
le premier à ne pas se plaindre de cette
relative modération syndicale c'est bien
entendu monsieur raymond barre qui peut
toujours y voir quant à lui une
conséquence de sa fermeté envers raymond
barre qui sera notre invité après demain
dans 1 c'est-à-dire spécial voilà point
final à cette grosse actualité socio
économique
juste un mot de politique sur cette
émulation cette compétition comme on
voudra au sein de la majorité
une petite phrase d'yves guéna ce matin
sur les propos de michel field ops qui
de voir les jeunes giscardiens hier en
nous attaquant michel villeneuve ce qui
dit il se trompe d'adversaire pour
l'instant le rpr de jacques chirac
prépare son premier meeting public en
province vendredi soir à strasbourg
présidée par le centriste pierre
pflimlin dans une interview à newsweek
jacques chirac a affirmé qu'il n'avait
pas l'intention de créer une crise
conduisant à des élections anticipées
veillée d'armes en espagne très
précisément avant veille de cette
première consultation électorale depuis
très longtemps le référendum c'est pour
après demain
tout cela dans un climat qui manquent
pour le moins de sérénité
il yad'abord depuis ce matin un mandat
d'arrêt lancé contre santiago carillo le
secrétaire général du pc et puis il ya
toujours les suite de l'enlèvement de
monsieur des orioles le président du
conseil d'état du royaume espagnol
toujours pas de nouvelles des ravisseurs
mais on a la certitude maintenant qu'il
s'agit d'un mouvement d'extrême gauche
48 heures après l'enlèvement du
président du conseil du royaume une
seule chose est sûre aujourd'hui d'après
la police et seulement d'après elle les
ravisseurs appartiennent un mouvement
révolutionnaire d'extrême gauche
cependant cet enlèvement restent encore
très mystérieux et il constitue à
quelques jours du référendum une
provocation très précises une sorte de
défi à l'autorité de l'état à madrid le
climat se tend chaque heure un peu plus
le premier ministre monsieur arese à
d'ailleurs annulé un voyage qu'il devait
faire demain en catalogne
toutefois on est bien persuadé ici que
les ravisseurs de monsieur auriol sont
manipulés par des éléments extérieurs au
pays et la police sur ce point reste
très prudente
c'est un signe ce matin également le
gouvernement a donné l'ordre à ses
policiers d'appréhender par tous les
moyens le leader communiste santiago
carillo
c'est un autre signe de la détérioration
politique du climat
après cet enlèvement monsieur cela ce
matin le gouvernement a décidé d'arrêter
et de localiser surtout le leader
communiste santiago carillo pour quelles
raisons
tout un coup subitement ou qui n'ont pas
ce que le kidnapping était très bien
très bien on fait la combine sida ça a
été fait une jours après que de santé
aux varois de naissance sa conférence de
presse à madrid
c'est aussi la provocation typique
camillo par la madre immédiatement tous
les forces de la droite pense que ça
c'est une violation de la loi espagnole
que c'était intolérable que les
gouvernements
et tolérer la présence car elle est ici
et pour les jours après c'est le
kidnapping
c'est une opération pour soulever tout
la protestation de l'extrême droite
trois bleus mandela mais on est certaine
partie de l'armée et alors après le
kidnapping les pressions sur le
gouvernement probablement été énorme
pour les forcer à l'hôtel ligne autour
du fort que d'ordre alors il a été
obligé de prendre cette décision au
moment de l'annoncé
est ce qu'à votre vie encore une
possibilité pour que le référendum n'est
pas lieu cela exclut j'espère que non la
capacité des barbaries t s'est pas
encore finie c'est à dire un baume dans
les métros se faire et horrible à
l'apparition de des orioles totalement
détruit physiquement ça va pousser un
énorme problème
est-ce que ce soir on peut exclure
l'assassinât des orioles ou pas je ne
risquerai pas c'est possible très
possible même trois jours avant le
référendum
même les jours de repos les jouera pas
au licou si on essaye réellement d'
arrêter notre marche vers la démocratie
ça ferait un joli voit la passe en une
frontière de la péninsule ibérique nous
sommes au portugal
là c'est un lendemain d'élection et
mario soares frotte les mains son parti
le parti socialiste s'est très bien
comporté d'une façon générale d'ailleurs
ces élections prouvent la stabilité de
l'électorat socialiste et centriste
cela dit alvaro cunhal cunhal parlant
lui aussi peut se montrer satisfait le
parti communiste a remonté c'est une
victoire importante déclare mario soares
sur journalistes alors que le
dépouillement se poursuit avec 35% des
voix le parti socialiste retrouve ses
suffrages des élections législatives du
mois d'avril
c'est donc un succès compte tenu des
mesures d'austérité adoptées par
l'équipe gouvernementale de monsieur
soaz
alvaro cunhal est lui aussi satisfait le
front électoral constitué autour du
parti communiste progressent nettement
il obtient près de 20% des voix alors
que le candidat du rdpc à l'élection
présidentielle portugaise avait
recueilli moins de 8%
autre caractéristique de la consultation
la stabilité des partis du centre et un
taux d'abstention jamais atteint dans
les scrutins précédents
plus de 35 % des inscrits enfin lisbonne
et porto les deux municipalités les plus
importantes du pays seront dirigées par
des élus socialistes c'est sûr il n'y
aura plus de géant dans la course
combattent l'antique en solitaire c'est
ce que vient de décider l'organisateur
anglais ça signifie que si les
règlements de la prochaine course avait
été appliqué cet été par plus de 18
mètres 50
alain colas n'aurait pas eu le droit de
se présenter au départ pas plus
d'ailleurs qu'eric tabarly fauconnier et
d'autres favoris de la course ce qui
paraît très tranchées qu'un site tous
les français qui avaient une chance
aurait été éliminé alors y aura-t-il
absence de fair-play des françaises sont
presque aussitôt décidé à organiser une
course parallèle décision raisonnable
peut être mais l'intérêt principal de la
transat c'était justement d'être une
course par un peu folle et c'est ce qui
faisait son succès l'atlantique
un homme un bateau au départ l'idée d'un
colonel anglais blondy hasler à la
première édition en 1965 concurrents en
1976 près de 150 la simplicité du
règlement de cette course lui avait
amené le succès populaire
ce que n'ont jamais connu d'autres
épreuves de voile
e moins de 18 médecins quand en 1981 ça
vous intéresse alain colas pas beaucoup
moi ce qui me passionne c'est s'est
laissé les gros bateaux parce que ça
représente un engagement physique à
l'engagement sportif très important et
puis aussi parce que c'est la voie du
progrès se brider à l'intérieur d'une
règle bon ben c'est ce qu'ont fait
volontiers dans le yachting
traditionnelle dans les mille et une
course qu'il ya deux parlements au cours
du programme de l'année
cette épreuve là était l'unique occasion
de développer des prototypes
on la supprime c'est un peu comme si
dans les sports automobiles ont supprimé
la formule en 24 heures du mans les
anglais ont la réputation d'être sportif
aussi cette nouvelle réglementation ne
peut être imputé au fait que la transat
est la seule épreuve de voile où ils
sont dominés par les français le trop
grand nombre peut-être mais dans
l'édition 76 les deux navigateurs
disparu en mer étaient deux marins
confirmés
alors eh bien ce sont les français qui
vont peut-être reprendre l'idée dassler
ainsi michel etevenon qui a déjà
participé au financement de nombreux
voiliers de course depuis six mois des
organismes m'a demandé de me pencher sur
l'organisation d'une grande course
française et j'hésitais beaucoup à
passer de l'autre côté et l'intérêt du
public allant toujours vers ceux qui
innovent et qui vont de l'avant je
médite plus je vais m'employer désormais
à tenter de mettre sur pied
l'organisation pour novembre 1978 d'une
course transatlantique réservée aux
bateaux par exemple à partir de 39 de
18,50 et où seul le moteur sera
interdite
il partira de france elle partira de
france mais nos amis britanniques ils
seront bien entendu les bienvenus dans
la transat anglaise de 1980 la
compétition sera sans doute moins inégal
et plus d'excès
les bateaux seront très proches les uns
des autres moins nombreux le départ mais
est ce suffisant
cette année en juin dernier ce n'est pas
le plus gros qui a gagné c'est eric
tabarly avec les 20 mètres de peine
et le deuxième n'était autre qu'un
modeste trimaran de 9 mètres 75 la
largeur du 80 d'alcool la mer égalise
souvent les chances et dans une épreuve
en solitaire comme la transat
elle fait la différence
c'est une véritable guerre économique
qui vient de s'engager entre l'europe et
le japon
à l'instant nous apprend que la
commission de là c'est l'europe des neuf
met au point des mesures de rétorsion
qu'elle pourrait appliquer au japon s'il
continue à monopoliser le marché mondial
des bateaux
valéry giscard d'estaing lui-même disait
hier que 90 % des commandes nouvelles de
bateaux ont été placés dans les
chantiers navals du seul japon l'année
dernière
de là le problème numéro un des
chantiers navals français de la
notamment ce conflit de saint nazaire
que nous avons évoqué en début de
journée c'est un dossier qu'il fallait
ouvrir et c'est ce qu'a fait pour nous
françois temps les bateaux sans emploi
l'armada des laissés pour compte dans
les fjords de norvège
on leur avait pourtant je fais c'est
comme à tous bon vent et bonne mer à ces
géants avant la crise du pétrole de 1974
aujourd'hui ils sont en chômage depuis
près de deux ans et royer à vendre
quatre fois moins cher que leurs coûts
de construction
mais personne n'en veut alors comme le
france au fond du port du havre
ils se roulent dans les eaux de norvège
ou d'ailleurs témoin d'une ère
aujourd'hui révolue celle de la
croissance économique rapide et
ininterrompue le surplus de pétroliers
mobilisés dans le monde est considérable
55 millions de tonnes l'équivalent d'une
centaine de super géants comme le pâtis
luce le plus grand des plus grand
actuellement qu'en service avec ses 550
mille tonnes à pleine charge
55 millions de tonnes de surplus en 1976
1977 et 1978
on en verra chaque année 12 millions de
tonnes à la casse mais ces retraits ne
suffiront pas à assainir le marché
les chantiers navals dans le monde ont
encore à livrer d'ici à 1978 81 millions
de tonnes de pétrole y est alors si le
transport maritime reste figée comme en
ce moment ce n'est pas l'équivalent
d'une centaine de superpétroliers de 550
mille tonnes qui seront au chômage
mais le double oui une page a été
tournée pour la construction navale dans
le mot est dans la meilleure des
hypothèses
la reprise des commandes n'interviendra
pas avant 1979
aujourd'hui c'est la guerre entre sous
les chantiers du monde la récession a
fait passer la france de la 4e à la 6e
place dans le classement des
constructeurs derrière le japon la suède
l'allemagne fédérale le royaume uni et
l'espagne
le carnet de commandes des chantiers
français portait sur plus de six
millions et demi de tonnes avant le
relèvement du prix du pétrole
en deux ans il a chuté de moitié tous
les chantiers navals ont été affectés
par la crise mais la france peut être
plus que d'autres
principal ennemi les japonais dans les
toutes récentes semaines ils ont rentré
tic grâce à une politique de rabais de
prix considérables jusqu'à 30 ou 40% en
dessous des prix européens
ils ont réussi à prendre dans certains
cas plus de 90% des commandes présentes
sur le marché
les japonais raffolent qu'actuellement
90% des commandes mondiales de navires
leur part dans la construction navale
était traditionnellement de 50%
ils se sont armés contre la crise en
cassant les prix et leur objectif est de
porter la production de leurs chantiers
à six millions et demi de tonneaux en
1980 ce qui représenterait près des
trois quarts de la demande mondiale à
cet horizon
en attendant la situation se dégrade
dans tous les pays européens
les essais de conservation entre
constructeurs ont donné jusqu'à
maintenant de très maigres résultats
devant ce déséquilibre les pays du
marché commun ou demander aux japonais
de réduire leurs constructions navales
si cette demande n'était pas satisfaite
les neufs pourraient alors prendre des
mesures de rétorsion et de
protectionnisme à l'égard du japon à
tokyo en a pris la menace très au
sérieux
le gouvernement s'est réuni à la fin du
mois dernier pour étudier cette demande
mais il n'a pas encore donné sa réponse
comme dans les autres pays de la
communauté européenne
les responsables des chantiers français
sont inquiets il emploie actuellement
trente mille personnes
ils se sont efforcés à l'époque du veau
gras de répondre à la demande face à
l'accroissement du commerce
international notamment dans le
transport pétrolier
aujourd'hui le tassement des échanges a
brutalement renversé la situation
les chantiers sont suréquipés et
l'avenir s'annonce plutôt sont le carnet
de commandes de la construction navale
française devrait assurer le plein
emploi jusqu'en 1978 mais au delà cette
date c'est l'inconnu les chantiers
français demandent l'aide de l'état pour
survivre les armateurs pour leur part et
c'est de jouer la solidarité
mais ce n'est pas toujours facile
lorsque leurs besoins sont pratiquement
néant et que les navires français coûte
parfois le double de ceux les
constructeurs japonais avec des écarts
de prix qui actuellement sont de l'ordre
de 30 à 100 % si on nous obligés de
commander dans les chantiers français il
n'y aurait tout simplement pas de
commande du tout le transport maritime
lui aussi est en sérieuse difficulté
les armateurs français passent la moitié
de leur commande à l'étranger notamment
au japon
simplement parce qu'ils paient leurs
bateaux moins cher si on les oblige à
acheter totalement français ils ne
passeront plus de commandes du tout
construction navale française marine
marchande en difficulté de raisons
profondes liées à la conjoncture
économique mondiale
des navires plus chers que ceux des
autres constructeurs et une flotte de
500 bateaux mal adapté au développement
de nos échanges internationaux
le commerce extérieur de la france vient
en quatrième position dans le monde
alors que notre marine marchande arrive
seulement au neuvième rang
rien d'aussi qui sera d'ailleurs évoqué
après demain au conseil des ministres
avant de nous quitter puisque nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure des programmes de
fans mais je voudrais vous annoncer qu'à
partir de jeudi chaque jour antenne 2 et
jacques chancel porteront leur regard
sur les chefs d'oeuvre du louvre une
émission quotidienne à 19h45
juste avant la caméra invisible la météo
pour terminer vous avez pu le constater
il a encore fait assez froid aujourd'hui
demain le temps sera très nuageux et
brumeux sur le nord sur la moitié sud
des prévisions un petit peu plus
encourageantes avec des éclaircies
annonce voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce
journal en or de compagnie au long de
toute la rédaction de la deux je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée
tout de suite le rappel litres bonsoir
les syndicats organisent l'action contre
le blocage du pouvoir d'achat un million
41 mille chômeurs en novembre 48 heures
avant le référendum toutes les
provocations sont possibles les anglais
change de règlement la transat plus de
monstres et moins de participants
dernier journal 23h25
m